i mean i was glad i i i don't know  basically i have no idea there you go  how can you how can you predict that i  mean you'd have to be  nostradamus mark two to get that one  right i mean uh d3 a really strange move  so he's played he's open with c3 now d3  next maybe e3 is gonna be next he's  played b3 c3 d3 e3 f3 g3 on the tour  just this season  i remember i remember talking to vidit  when he was uh playing in the  middleweight championship store before  and how how much he respects magnus  carlsen how much he's meant to him being  just four years younger trying to with  the whole background of a non and then  he comes out and he throws d3 at you  after you probably prepared quite a lot  what does that do to you yeah it throws  you off and imagine vidit has spent  nearly one minute thinking of his reply  on move one  it's definitely psychologically it's